all right and we are live the last word
featuring Laura Cognito Edie Bartus
returns
hot by the campfire everybody's huddling
in it's getting warm what is going on
eat how you doing sir I'm doing pretty
good
it is Friday it's been a busy week you
know word and I had family in town this
past weekend got some coming in town
this like weekend we got events going on
for this game that we play like so much
is happening on Tuesday so we will talk
about all that just working on got my
Titan no yeah my Titan is 950 plus like
12 something like 962 working on the
warlock so I feel like I'm behind the
power grind but it's it's getting there
and then of course everything's
exploding and mayhem so that's always
fun
yeah man I started very strong top of
the week
grind is about 962 963 something that
something like that and I'm kind of I
hit that wall I hit that wall will
discuss you know finally experience what
everyone was talking about so we
definitely will discuss that but um yeah
just working on pinnacles discussion
that's a slight topic of discussion a
little comp and you know just pretty
much it just kind of chillin and
actually I booted up the outer worlds so
I'm guys man I would highly recommend it
it's from my favorite one of my favorite
developers obsidian if you guys are fans
of the original Fallout series like the
Fallout New Vegas is and you know I'm
saying like the original where they were
kind of more crowded in the skill trees
and the deep characters and dialogue
choices and all that loving it right now
I would say it's like a happy marriage
fallout meets Mass Effect with the space
stuff meets Borderlands with the humor
and I'm enjoying it man I couldn't stop
playing it launched at midnight and for
those on PC or Xbox it's in-game pass
y'all like literally like it's a free
download I would tell you guys little
solo distraction so check it out man I
don't worry
I've been feeling it it's gonna say what
are you doing playing another game and
this is destiny time sir I'll tell you
why will we talk about pinnacles alright
fair enough
[Laughter]
but yeah so we've got a lot of stuff
coming up this future week we had iron
banner continue I played a fair amount
over the weekend Monday slash so got it
got a decent amount in there so we'll
touch on that a little bit we've got as
we kind of now bump up towards this 950
level there is a nice topic to talk
about when it comes to pinnacles then
we'll get into the festival we will get
into the Bungie charity topic and then
which is awesome and then we'll talk
about what is coming next week as well
so we've got a lot of stuff upcoming on
the roadmap pretty tight here pretty
quick so just start how much more where
did you feel iron banner kind of ended
up landing this time honestly oh you
didn't play that much I was until like
Monday and then I just like no life did
I no life did probably like a you know
two days after it dropped um you know
pinnacle sources were dropping um I fun
with it you know I mean again I'm very
biased towards PvP so you know the fact
I was actually surprising it would be
made it a pinnacle source so uh you know
just running around with that I had a
couple of six stack shots on my xbox
guys little rocking I had a couple of
six stacks just smashing fools and
having fun and oh you're one of those I
see how it is yeah I was I was I was
that I was that guy so I bet it was
enjoyable for me yeah that's just good
time shooting up with your friends
blowing people up ours possum bubbles
for defense getting that weapons of
light just melting folks it's manual I
was super sweaty I have recluse go and
shout out to mountaintop to like no I'm
not desperate
I was super sweaty no but I had on I had
juju recluse and then I was going on old
school
you know just long-range machine gun
purposes you know I was doing that I
like never see camera head in a
competitive environment that's such a
unique lineup I mean there's no one
that's doing that right so that uh so I
will say this I like to change is to
have the ammo I was able to get some ham
every ammo a match you know I'd have to
worry about the e-bot Isis on my team
that's run break that was I was working
on a quest I never claimed to be
honorable during that moment but
normally paved now you get to share
anyway what are you talking X that's
what I said I'm so happy about things I
was like wait a minute I'm getting heavy
every bet I'm not used to this without
flavory but like I know okay let me ask
you that know when you're playing with
your six deck and if you guys are like
control on the map are you just laying
is heavy a joke even more you just like
start stepping on him even harder like
it's to be honest I think it's it's in a
good place because it's so limited the
amount that you get shared so you may be
able to get two kills but you're not
hoarding on to this thing getting four
or five and not not with this so it's
right one two and it's done I always say
like maybe 24 shots really really a
minimal amount just enough to make you
get like one or two guarantee kills but
that's it
so just doing that and um you know just
messing around with the meta scouts are
definitely in a better place
I'm seeing guys around he in PvP yes I'm
not there I'm not there I'm going no no
yeah yeah yep you've been having bad
experiences with us I mean it's I go to
use them and I'm just sitting there and
they're just like I still feel like I'm
just plinking away and I just it just
doesn't feel I haven't sat there and
done a damage test and I need to but not
everything is like 950 so some places
doing damage is not it was gonna be the
same I need to go shoot Greg like
everybody else does but shadows to cross
um
I'll shout out the cross yes yes it's
just man if you ever pull one out and
you're just like ping ping ping ping
you're like yeah it's just not enough
bullets first uh it just doesn't feel
right in PvP or PvE PvP it's okay like
I've been killed by plenty i've got a
couple kills like pulled out bad juju to
try it out there's a lot of people
running my for the scout rifle
and then if anybody's got randy's though
oye trainees do Randy's is that thing
speedy that's a speedy boy quick kills
man that hurts andis is nice big big fan
of that I will say the longer maps are
definitely playing the scouts I'm
getting killed by I'm getting killed by
the occasional Maya I'm getting killed
by some scouts that I'm like okay it
actually wasn't mad I was all right you
know what that makes and got ya guys are
laying in man they're late and they'll
they'll like two three laying out and
then rock out so hey it's your sales
like scout team shot it now yes TV
judgment isn't it just shot the neil
mental yeah fusion rifles are everywhere
shout out the air until shout out the
whizzing rebuke they are out there in
these trees did the jig's up on me I was
one of my flows to I was used to use my
air until credit it's everywhere now so
I see in that I got a DVD I don't have a
good air until I for the life of me I
cannot get a good one much less get I've
had like two drops since it became a
possibility I forgot about that now I
did get the licen rebuke I got a couple
from only iron banner that I played
though and I was doing some pretty good
shots with that one I think it was
hidden mm-hmm like 4849 a bolt like it
was wizened was license really high on
impact so if you can't random and it's
fairly tight like you can hit pretty
good it's not as fast like Aaron's Hills
still probably gonna outshoot me but I
was like it was it was cool I was
enjoying it because when I had to get
the fusion rifle kills those like how's
this gonna be it actually went pretty
well yeah yeah yo I got a complaint
though man saladin man well I got prop
bro when is this man gonna give me swarm
what spike grenades oh man like three of
them bro it is so yeah I got one I was
at once
it dropped I looked at United you should
see the initial perks you can't telling
something right so I'm like whoa rampage
okay open it up explosive I'm like no
spike meant like it is driving me nuts
so it's yeah man I want my old my I want
my all void arm line
because I really got a sick build right
now with all necessary sin
I'm running that I'm running that at
that grenade the one that weakens
enemies it takes like six in the class
item and then it's another one that you
put in the chest that's from the
artifact so I got this like void stat
and then with Nezzer ik any void kill
but uh you know um they're clues you
know for all colony I could be really
disgusting and just I'm getting my super
I'm getting energy it is such a fun
build man and it's just like needs need
the small bed it just it just sounds
like you got options though you've got
other other ways to play the game I'm
gonna tell you why the reason why I'm
complaining is because I'm such a
izanagi fanboy yeah it tears yeah planet
is my optimal sweat PvE loadout cannot
be complete user because I don't it's
not as good as Islam small new people
you are wrecking bosses i watch your
videos i see what you doing out there
and then ascended challenges and melting
odd meets wrong give me the Saladin
let's go it's been like three I abandons
for him I mean you have storms you just
haven't had the spike roll but you can
still have a void grenade launcher
you're just being all picky one the
spiky don't give me don't give me that
edge transit garbage
I want aggressive frame swarm y'all
that's what we need
picky it's just too picky sweaty but
yeah I mean iron banner was I don't know
for me like the the bounties were not
bad I ended up saving those cuz I wasn't
quite 950 but I got 950 on all gear then
I turned them in so I've got a few 950
ones already since I saved oh nice so
I've still got those like I think five
saved on my warlock so when I get there
won't be too long so like getting those
950 once is okay and we'll talk about
that pinnacle thing here in a minute but
for me it was
I don't know did you want I know we
didn't get a vendor refresh so I'm not
surprised yes we got the armor set not
bad-looking I haven't really shaded it
up much but it's there it's you know
you're a warlock you think the warlocks
don't like it the most like it's not bad
it's not it's for you guys it's great
for us I think the hunters got a pretty
cool cloak too but
Titans apparently you guys are not the
biggest fans in the world it's a clean
set though I mean it's clean like it's
like future space it's not like 1969
Tyco not space helmet it's actually like
hey if you're gonna go to space in your
Guardian you're like yeah probably
survive I just need like my robe and
just a little helmet like it's like it's
clean but the fact that there were no
new weapons it was not like not one no
new weapon and this is where the vendor
refresh again comes around and just
feels a little feels a little more
because we don't we don't have Vanguard
we don't have crucible we don't have
anything at the planets and it's like I
can understand the planets even before
like Vanguard and crucible because those
are like towers you'll see them a lot
more frequently yeah
iron banners like a big deal and that's
one of those points where you're like
I'm getting another crew Milly's dagger
or claws of the wolf which are fine
they're decent guns but I don't know
that's just one of those where that's
how like even if the planetary vendors
which would be cool that's just that is
a lot of sets to go through that would
be more if we could at least start with
the tower it's a good place to start do
that no I think that was definitely a
misstep to not have any new weapons in
iron banner and um yeah I mean listen we
we mean you've complained for a while
you know we we feel that you know these
refreshes they got a comment I mean I'm
saying because you gotta keep this old
content alive you gotta you got a really
great it and I didn't think about it but
you're right I'm like like we didn't get
not one you know you just get no drops
you know said it's just like okay you
know the font from the weapon pool at
least so they one would hope they've got
to get that going man especially you
know this next season we need refreshes
in the worst way vendors everybody needs
a refresh these smooth things man in the
matte
well and that's a hard thing to ask when
you think about a season because I mean
how much bandwidth do they have for like
where is all their work going in a
season is it on vindow refreshes or is
it on whatever content is company are
they mostly rabbi miss content up
because they're working on season and
flake past the season of dawn like where
do their priorities live it's vinda
refresh is probably are not that high on
it so yeah and it's unfortunate but it's
like in fairness to them it's just
probably not that high and it's just
there's other things they're working on
so I agree I agree like I said if you
put it all in a box and you prioritize
it you know that's probably where it's
fallen and I have no issue with it based
on how much I'm enjoying shadow keeping
everything else but calm like the next
seasons like we got to get this going
out you know I'm saying hopefully you
know things of its risen up the totem
pole and you know longer trials and
other things you'd understand that got
that got to come back so yeah I think
it's gonna happen I just think with
everything involved with shadow keeps
launch whether it be the cross save and
you know all the platform stuff and you
know III just and obviously them free
from you know Activision but calm next
season I'm gonna be going in now I'm not
gonna be as a forgiving you know say if
I see certain repetitive things that
address so yeah again this is the grace
period for me where I'm now well shadow
keep we got more content we got the
season we got the moon stuff like
there's a decent amount going on next
season will be the tell as to how the
rest of the year looks because yeah the
moon may stay but if we lose the vex
offensive and get one new thing how much
do you love die mare hunts like night
falls have a lot of thing but they're
like they're very limited grind for a
certain thing and even in there like
once you kind of get some of those
things then like there's yeah we got to
see how things go for playing out the
future
it's an ancient in the omentum made a
good point faction rallies although it's
like give me my faction rallies shaders
I want my new monarchy stuff you and
your shiny gold you gotta have that
bling
go there with the lion on it how are you
not a Titan
Yeah right you would think yes
personality would fit tight like you
look like a Titan you like the Lions you
wanted colors like we're why how are you
not Titan
I remember booting up destiny for the
first time and warlock was the first
thing that came up on my screen and you
know what I know what did it when you
see him holding the glowing ball yep oh
this guy wields the power I like this
you know I just fell in love when I was
like yo so let the time that's right now
looked at I was like that's something
I'm gonna pick right cause I know tight
is what I would normally gravitate
towards to play bro when I saw it was a
tough choice actually all three honestly
I have feelings for all three Titan big
bruiser
you know smash stuff hunter because I
love ninjas and they feel stealthy they
feel you know they look cool you know
like country's got a cool look to him
you know but when I saw that warlock man
it was just it was just doing something
out of worldly I was like new monarchy
good lord man that's right you better
salute her daily you CREP right now you
I know better he'd better put respect or
her gales name we don't mess with the
skiddo clan what's the skittle claim
what's that clanging I'm asking a future
war called yeah taste of rainbow we
doing that and they they over there in
that little room you don't have room
where they got Starbucks in future yes
but like bubble chairs I am definitely
not doing a rock jello crazy band of
space guys that want to run and I like
your shaders know back in d1 I love the
shadiest I was dead over at the
beginning because of the shaders but I
mean a rock can't do it man can't do it
man so right now new marquee he changed
his gear set maybe I'm just all about
the fashion as soon as somebody changed
it to a better suit you know I'll jump
ship it new body Andy to set it off I
literally was like dead orbit whoo oh
boy everybody wanted that dead orbit
shader though and nobody can get that
yeah
so yeah but I'd like the omental yeah
and you know tell us who you like but it
was actually I had a good idea he was
just to like mix things up and I don't
know if this is something they could do
balance wise but he was just saying I'd
like to run double kinetics or double
elements also you if you could just run
the two slots basically wide open and
just pick between those two like pick
one pick the other and switch them cuz
he's saying it's like I'd like to use
fighting line and loaded question mmm oh
okay okay so like I could actually see
cuz fighting lines a primary or I mean
maybe you just want to put two energy
weapons and then you know you won't be
as much that would be like they limit
you so much with like match game and
stuff like that if you could run two
different energies and then that locked
loadout it would just be nicer because
sometimes I don't really care about a
kinetic if I can break multiple shields
that's one of those like strategy things
but environment English audio I know
actually I hadn't really ever thought
about that that much that would become
interesting so for them to bring back
for d2 for sure yeah next season next
season's yeah lot on the road I will be
very curious when we see that new like
if we get a schedule of season of dawn
like what's coming Windows Osiris show
up like when is he coming aim is giving
me hope a day when I hit God and give
you out like it's all it's gotta be fire
cuz everything right now is a void an
arc and fires like nowhere like
mentioned in the game you were just void
are annoyed hard he's gonna come back in
the port like somebody I know would blow
you oh my god there it is fire fine boy
got come back boy he's been gone he's
doing something he's doing something
with them vex me also what would you do
if when the portal in the tower is done
mm-hmm
like orbs like a Osiris and he blocks in
I'm gonna go crazy but I bought theory
my magical dream theory is that her plan
is a mistake and the tower gets either
attacked or whatever and they're like
that little cinematic look full of he
comes through you're at I said this is
the true play like all but I got I got
theories I got theories but we'll see
we'll see what happens man let's see
hoping that you know this hole because
the VEX offensive has to end somehow by
some way well we're gonna kill the
multiple copies of the undying mind like
all over so my general assumption is the
portals gonna open my core is gonna be
like here go back to the portal hit
whatever go in to go through the portal
wherever we're gonna go and then we're
gonna go fight the undying mind as
millions of guardians and kill him
hundreds and thousands of times if we do
that then that might shut it down but I
was like I don't know where the seasons
gonna wrap it on a season of dawn ties
in I'm hoping what Cyrus does come
because he got kind of shafted on his
season in his expansion didn't get it
now some people may be like Osiris me
like no stay away cuz cuz it is like a
tarnished name but I do think he has he
is a big enough character it would be
nice to see him redeemed mm-hmm say Fred
to disrespect how you gonna do me like
that bro he said Osiris I'll handle this
guardians perceived to disappear for the
entire oh so true it's what I do
yeah you even run a strike and be like
oh well I made another copy I'm sorry
can you go fix this for me he's just
like tripping over his own feed now he
was alone we gonna do that back when
Osiris man stating facts he's a facts
man gotta roll with the facts in this
listen I Korra learned from the best
alright so right now she thinks she
knows what she's doing but she needs
some senior leadership that's all some
senior leadership an expert in the ways
of the pêche this is the only one in the
tower showing leadership come on yeah to
be real was just like yeah I'm cruisin
on my tear I just got my I got my rail
and lean against Ted I'm over here I
just lean this is where I lean let's go
to I can't wait for next season I was
gonna happen to but even before next
season gets here we've actually got a
lot coming up next week so for me we've
got a dungeon we've got festivals lost
we've got final offensive and all those
things but what are you gonna be working
on while you work towards those things
what do you what are you trying to grind
for sir what does leave a certain number
you're going forward you
thing your do you feel like you're
limited do you feel like you can get to
that final peak yeah I know do we want
to talk about it now we going right into
it right yeah let's get to it like this
is a unique place for me right now with
destiny um obviously we all started you
know the grind you know what drops were
useful everything was going in you know
right right up to 900 and then you know
you're going from the 900 to get 950 and
it was just a steady progression you're
unlocking your artifact you're getting
those extra you know points to your gear
score and all that other good stuff and
it's been great and then obviously you
hit that 950 plus and then you see every
drop is 950 right and it's just like you
know so it's like it's one of those
things where everything really really
slows down and actually it becomes way
harder but as we started saying last
week you start to realize yo there's not
a lot of pinnacle sources for the
hardcore that have now reached this cap
it was just that iron banner right and
run the raid right so basically the four
drives from the raid if you run raids
but I'm saying nothing from PvP that's
giving you give me that and then I mean
was apologize a banner technically there
was a limited time event but that was
that was exactly so that was this so it
put me in this strange position where
it's like I don't have to do these other
challenges like I'm so you we're so used
to logging in that's okay man I got to
camp these all these sources of powerful
gear now powerful gear is not pinnacle
gear it not helping you so it's a it's a
different thing and I felt my choices
shrank when that happened
then it became okay let me work on
leviathans breath obviously you know
that's that's that came out um a couple
other things but it really slowed me
down honestly because the way I looked
at it was this eat yes there's a raid
and yesterday's banner but the way it's
structured it's only doing you plus one
per gear slot and then you're hoping on
orange and with my orangey I always get
everything pinnacle in an image like
1951 for life yeah energy me to death
energy energy energy stuff so I'm like
okay cool but the realities i sat to
myself like why am I going to kill
myself for a plus-one but for a hope of
a plus-one it's really not doing that
much and then the way like when you
talked about it last last last word was
on earth or last last word yesterday
yesterday previous last week what
previously on the last word come back we
digress sorry anyway we digress so it's
like if you look at the math the
probabilities that's that's that's
daunting so I have a theory you know my
first of all my thing right now slow
down I'm not killing myself you know I
will run the raid because I want rate
stuff I'll run banner and stuff like
that but until more sources or reveal
and I think that's what they're doing
and I know you're gonna be about to go
in my gut is that they are trickling out
the pinnacle stuff I think I know the
community shout out the Tolono so these
guys taxi they got a great podcast on
this discussion I don't we talked about
a pre-show you know rage this roundtable
knows guys and a lot of guys are
freaking out they like yo this is not
enough source of what's going on you
know the hard core data and I get it
I think this is bungees way of slowing
us down and they're gonna drip feed us
Pinnacle sources I think we're gonna get
you know obviously the dungeon that's
coming you know we've got the Hunts and
all that stuff that's coming we got to
see how to seize little event is handled
you know obviously that but I think this
is just a complete new approach I'm not
saying this is the right way or not I
still think this is a new approach that
they are still messing with and
experimenting with but let me leave get
you lit before to you because I'd know
you got a lot to say about this mr.
Harcourt himself
so
oh yeah shadow trade just learn table it
was like to listen to it yesterday at
work just killing some time and they had
an interesting idea and kind of a
discussion point because right now math
lies I mean we got the master nightmare
hunts those are pinnacle
we have the nightfall which is a
pinnacle if you hit a hundred K you have
the raid which is what for something
like that so six six six pinnacles and
we have a ten week season right and you
have to get eight drops on your
character so ten times 6 is 60 drops and
then eight times what do you need 10
levels you need 80 drops and that's
perfection that is no our geez that's
not for energy weapons in a row that's
not for class items none of that and so
the major show yeah the major issue a
lot of people are having no protection
orangy can screw you and you can be 951
for 4 weeks the raid does not have a
heavy so you could be 959 why run the
nightfall get a helmet in your like son
of it and you have to wait another week
and then you don't axe then at that
point you're running the raid over and
over again getting more 950 once because
you can't get heavy to find that one
slot yep
we do have the nightmare hunt now which
I guess could give another option for
potentially just random heavy drop so
there's two in these but there's no
protection like if you're 951 and that
one slot sitting at 950 how many drops
do you need to have dropped not to be
that not that one that the game should
finally just be like okay give him a
heavy right like how many do you think
that should be first off that's kind of
what do you think there should be RNG
protection when it comes to the pinnacle
grind at all it has to be just a wait
for this the way it's currently
structured in shadow keep it has to be
because right now it is clear you cannot
you have to have Orin Jesus from the
gods like you but daily like daily for
this all this stuff to drop on your lap
in that way so to me this is purposely
done this is this is I don't I won't
call it a form of hardcore throttling
only the way I'm looking at it is they
are looking at this artifact as your way
of leveling for the hardcore the vibe
I'm getting the old way we used to think
is is currently over they are saying get
bow knees do activities that's going to
give you bonus light come season over
that's going to reset you will drop so
that I don't know that that that's the
vibe that's the vibe I'm getting you
know I'm saying that this is a new way
that they are handling leveling and I
don't know if every obviously
everybody's gonna agree with it you know
obviously the season is still young we
still have a bunch of events that we
don't know how they're gonna handle but
it's a contentious subject I see you're
where you're going you know I'm saying I
don't I'm not saying you're wrong or
anything I'm just saying it's clear to
me the old way is not it for hardcore
like that that this is not what we're
our mind is accustomed to when it comes
to grinding and leveling it's all about
artifact XP bounties and I guess
rewarding continued commitment to the
game in that sense and you know we got
to see how the community going rock with
this you know where's your head at so I
mean the RNG protection would be nice to
a point like if you right now you would
even have to have our Tea Party
protection guaranteed and if you like
slept in and missed iron banner you
could get it either way yeah so that's
that that's a thing in and of itself
just because we're talking about people
trying to get everybody was wants to get
that highest level that is like one of
the big goals in this one and as you
said that shifted mentality to the
artifact is all about that exp now
that's not a completely bad thing mmm
like when you get to a point like you go
into you play these paragon levels
you're not gonna make vast increases but
as you go through you get a little
better get a little better get a little
better and as you go through and you do
bounties and you go do the raid
play some PvP and you hit that that
experience loop keeps going and slowly
bumpin that bonus powerup that's gonna
get there and that's gonna make up for
you know 951 952 forever to a point I
mean we have a 980 difficult thing if
you're 950 Plus about 12 when everybody
seems to get there you're about 962 so
you're within 20 so you won't get
completely smashed but you really gotta
go run your highest stuff otherwise it's
gonna hurt ya but the other question
they had and I did want to bring this up
and kind of see what Chet thinks about
this as well because not everybody
listens everything so it was a decent
topic so they had two different
mentalities as opposed to this entire
year so when we talk about the pinnacle
grind we're like okay so previously what
had happened was a new season comes out
a bump the power level 50 you'll grind
out your 50 with powerful gear okay they
have a different change of mentality
because they have the ala carte seasons
so you have somebody that skips season
of dong comes in for season 10 if I can
do math and then they come in and
they're like hey do I have to grind up
to a thousand 50 mm-hmm or are they
gonna handle it differently and this is
where they kind of got into their topics
and this is why I'm really curious like
both you and chat and I'm kind of torn
so Paul Tassie had him on here awesome
guest writes for Forbes if you don't
follow him on Twitter follow him on
Twitter awesome guy Lord of nerves
that's my new intro for him when he
comes back oh man dude he's gonna laugh
so hard at that good a lasso or I roll
one of the two I roll and laugh and
chuckle we gotta bring him back so much
fun yeah so he was on the side of
traditional like past couple years that
we've seen so season Abdallah bumped the
level up to a thousand the pinnacle
might be to you know 10 10 you get a new
artifacts who'd be working on grinding
that out you got powerful gear now it's
kind of how it's been the other side of
the equation is what Lona was saying
shout out to say no to rage and low No
his idea was that this pinnacle grind
950 to 960 is all year it's meant to
need ultra
slow when you win the you get a new
artifact you're gonna go down to 951 or
950 950 wherever you were you're gonna
drop down and you've got to earn the
bonus power again you've got to unlock
the new mods and you're gonna go through
that grind and go back up to 980 now his
thoughts on that were like hey we have
980 night falls in there
well if you bump it up to a thousand do
you adjust the difficulty on those but
their mentality was Bungie wants to be
like hey you want to buy the Alucard
season you don't have to do you have to
do these catch-up mechanics and things
like that in the new seasons so like I
haven't let me let me let me back up one
thing just to help your gonna sway what
nonno was saying and what you're saying
so what he's arguing just want to clap
for clarity is that the artifact now
when it goes away I'm gonna like every
season he's saying that it's gonna go
back down the 950 and then 980 again is
just gonna stay between 950 980 there
won't be any progression number wise
then he's gonna stay at these numbers
the gear score will be staying around
there that was his that was his thought
because his thoughts behind that were
that Bungie wants to allow people to
come in new seasons playing them all
Acharya so if you do it all cart and
you're like hey I played shadow keep up
to 951 and I didn't play season of dawn
but I came back in march on 951
everybody else's will baby like 955 cool
not that far behind I'm gonna grind out
the new artifact that's his take on what
they're trying to do because ability I
was like it's so the other side Tassie's
like I can't see that and that's I think
I have to lean more towards Tassie just
because I can't picture powerful gear
being like powerful drops being useless
for nine months and I think that's my
biggest thing is like - if you but a
nice and he's okay so then the wonders
okay so do you make the new master night
falls like 10:30 like do you adjust
difficulty but then do people who jump
in who skipped nine jump in at 10:00
do they get a bump with like the
boosters that they were doing last year
I like they brought that topic up and
I've been thinking about it I'm like I
really want Bungie to tell me what the
hell is going on cuz like I'm like what
do you think what would you prefer and
what do you think is gonna happen
because those
not even be the same thing all right
first of all you know like like you said
they have not been clear on their
thought process and motivation with how
this is gonna work
continuing on pasture shadow key right
so all this we do it is speculation but
you know which is fun so we gonna do it
so at the end of the day I mean I think
what I'm with you and Tassie in a sense
of if they do that thing we go down and
we say to 950 then we got to go back up
through the artifact then it it
literally eliminates powerful drops the
whole purpose of powerful drops will be
going because once you get to 950
regardless of its Alucard new player
then all you're doing is looking for
Pinnacle stuff and I just can't see that
being the grind enough to beat it I
don't think that's sufficient to be the
grind right now so I still think my old
mentality of destiny still has to work
where you know there's a new number
right whether it be a thousand whatever
the new number is the new chase number
power change number and then we still
ascend now yes there will be a reset
because a reset of the artifact because
that's extra leveling you know that
they're gonna say okay for the guys that
went hardcore you guys are 989 90 you're
not starting off yeah you're not
starting what's the highest light you've
seen with somebody's I saw somebody 975
on destiny tracker here I looked okay
yeah so mister 975 it was cute for this
season you're the man but come next
season season to dawn you're writing
pocket with 950 and then BOOM new level
again and then that's how my destiny
mind works and I guess how it is I'm not
saying that
laurels not completely they may they may
change the only argument on III side
with a little is the a la carte thing
for people just jumping in cuz if you
just jump in right your new destiny guy
you didn't you know you like okay I'm
jumping in shadow key what did you start
off are you just gonna be 750 then you
gotta rise your way up they may do that
or it is interesting it is interesting
I'm leaving you got I'm leaning you
ain't a seed
I think it's still gonna be traditional
I still think it's going to be a new
light level I still I think that the
artifact artifact reset will only affect
additional power level past that cap and
then that gets shut down and then you
start again and then new artifact new
ways they want you to play and new
additional power on top of it that's
what my gun is leaning and that's kind
of like that's why it's like I'm really
curious what Bungie says on this one
because you have the idea of this
pinnacle grind that it's just an
absolute hell for some people what if
you get to 9:55 next season the power
levels thousand somebody gets a boost up
to 950 mm-hmm and then in five minutes
you just passed that level so then you
like how does that pinnacle grind feel
if we do keep climbing and again I love
the mentality that I want to keep
climbing so I have it's really weird
actually because I got a question for
you - yeah yeah I did here's the thing
that for you guys that are saying that
and I understand where you're coming
from based on our mentality of playing
destiny all these years right I know
they're changing stuff yeah right but my
question is you don't like it to me like
you guys don't look at that no yeah look
at the artifact number as a fake number
like I look at it like I'm 960 something
you know I mean I think of that as fake
that's not what I'm saying
mine's when we're just like you're worth
like hitting that level getting that
bonus powers like cool in 963 964 965
and I see a climbing which is great you
don't like clothes and clothes are
harder stuff that's cool actually really
do like the artifact for that because
that feels if they play in power
yeah 1.3 million experience one point
four billion experience it's like I know
I'm hitting those thresholds and I'm
like I'm a lot closer to that like a
little closer a little higher like
everything is like those nine aiders are
getting slowly more attainable but in
turn is like then kind of like then I
might end up being more like you though
with the pinnacle like right if I'm 950
how much stuff am I really going for
then it's like you're looking at tidal
grinds and triumphs and other stuff
finish a pinnacle weapons and things as
opposed to worrying about do I break my
head against the 980 you know stuff or
whatever like trying to get a pinnacle
drop like 100k you can almost get to
anyway so it's like what and
where is the incentive for the pinnacle
and especially if it gets overlapped
like how much really will it really
matter because I mean you're talking
about like three or four levels five
levels that you might get if you're
orangey lucky you might end up like what
if you were like 958 right but then say
you sleep in on the next expansion first
day somebody does a whole bunch of stuff
and they're like 958 on the first day
does your grind get lessened or is that
just something for the hard core to have
that that extra like reaches the wall
and be like I'm a little little farther
out than you not much but I know if I
got to 9:57 gear score that's bragging
rights that I absolutely killed myself
for it and then new season we goes fresh
like I'm kind of wondering I I think
based on again it's just guessing
estimation you know is that their new
thing like you see how they got the not
the what is it the master knife forward
is that 980 or whatever it is yeah 980
right okay so the vibe I get from them
based on its like okay they're telling
you you can only get these specific
rewards you get I think they're putting
things in the chase and they're turning
the game in to tune in next week you
notice when you boot into destiny now
right yo tune in this week such--such
happening that's portal open hey like
Maradona turn to this Hey like now it's
becoming this event the the everything
is an event week to week and if you
remember Luke Smith's commentary right
they want this to be this evolving world
right so I think the problem the
hardcore may have is sitting there
getting caught up with the number right
that full disclosure that's why I slowed
down towards the end of this week cuz I
was like okay what do I need hit my hip
my I hit my max I got everything I need
I'm just gonna work on that on the
violence what you call it breath cuz
obviously a powerful weapon I want to do
that let me see what's gonna happen when
the dungeon drops ha what's the pit is
it gonna obviously better be pinnacle
one one think it should be pitiful do
you think it's one do you think it's
three I mean is it just is it powerful
drops and then finishing it's worth like
one pinnacle probably you got to see you
know me i won
I'm falling back from killing myself
because I want to see how they handle
each subsequent event and I think this
is where they may I don't say have a
mutiny with the hardcore because I don't
think the hardcore are like super upset
I just think the hardcore or worried
right cuz they like yo I ain't got much
to do cuz I'm all there's only these two
East couple of Pentacles that's only
gonna give me plus one and that's not
inspiring
so letting is let's wait let's see it
play out
especially this next week this we're
gonna learn a lot this next when the
dungeon oh we're gonna learn a lot we're
gonna learn a lot I think they aren't
some very slow revealing and I will say
this if they do say another plus one and
there's still gaps with you know plus
ones and not in certain categories one
more they definitely don't want more
more than that so that that's where I
think we stand and and I this is an
incomplete great that's how I look at it
this is in comes we don't have all the
information we do not have all the
information so before I can go and say
y'all stay screw and I can't do that you
know I'm saying I can understand the
concern I definitely understand exert
but I just want to see they clearly got
a plan they clear that the heart the
regular Joe he's still grinding right
now he's still you know a lot of guys
ain't even do it raid yet but us I got
Joey I thought I was like I am NOT
there's only like two or three power
sources
I did my nightfall I did my garden
salvation I am not killing myself for no
plus one you know I'm saying I'm sorry
that's not happening I got better things
to do so I'll tune in next week when
dungeon opens up wherever it's gonna
open up and we're gonna see where's that
that's where every week is a new thing
to tune in for you know said that's how
I'm looking at destiny right now what
about you where you at where's the
station level
no it's like I'm barely I was like I hit
950 just because I've been slower with
you know family and stuff like that so I
haven't been quite there but it's like I
hit 950 and you do look at like okay so
the big thing you want to focus on at
950 bounties bounties management
pennies pennies pennies like I mean
literally bounteous till you're blue in
the face like if you go play some
crystal make sure you get some bounties
oh yeah I got finished all my bounties
hold on let me go back to the tower and
pick up more bounties by the way can I
please pick up bounties from the dam
director yes time it's time it's I agree
it's like I can get to the ever restore
in the director let me go access those
little screens just let me pick up even
if it's just the repeatable just the
stuff that you can get like let me get
the repeatable x' in the director so if
I'm like waiting between matches I don't
have to fly into the tower fly back out
finding out about such an extra step
that just needs to be avoided yeah I
mean the repeatable bug bounties I love
them they are absolutely amazing there
as I said I probably said it before it
one of those things we didn't know we
wanted but I'm so happy that it's in
there like oh happy cuz I mean if you
want to play PvP or you I want to do
iron banner for a while you had a
repeatable iron banner bounties and
repeatable crucible felonies I'm getting
a lot of exp and then I'm not just
wasting my time in there I'm actually
working on stuff kind of has me steer to
play a little different way maybe I'll
use a sniper rifle this round maybe I'll
play art in this round so it gives me
yeah it is it helps and especially as
you're working on that artifact to get a
bonus power level all the bounties you
can get are always a good thing
so yes I've never sitting at max slimmer
though I can tell you that yeah and I
mean they're like hundred fifty years up
and down like I got to 190 that was down
the 120 was like Jesus yo my black armor
how's your black arm rehearsal going my
resources getting there a little bit
yeah what you don't like member would be
I'm not running for just Y so no no not
for just I'm talking about all right
hustle no we did the house to D oh yeah
yeah yeah oh I'd like $7 in class I had
all that stuff on e d0 and I really
don't have been I haven't used them that
much oh so you don't even use your
you're not even using your upgrade
modules no I used a few of those I just
haven't been I've been picky with them
but I haven't like every single thing
just like pump up like I just hit 950 so
now I'll probably start going through me
like now yeah this one can be this one
like yeah we start doing that more me
all right I wouldn't know how your
material no I've got like 25 of them
they're probably all about to start be
like okay yeah that's probably started
go okay I just curious continue ya know
so yeah the repeatable bounties are
great and it's just it's that is all
towards that artifact is all that bonus
power txp is what you're really gonna go
for at this point so if you duel of
Destiny you do have a way to continually
level work towards that power
progression and get higher even if the
pinnacle is ultra slow I guess the final
question on this point so we have been
here for a while do you think this
season pinnacle math is a little weird
we don't have all the sources yet we
know there may be more but come next
season you're so you're gonna have the
raid mm-hm I don't know if we're getting
any new raids but for the time being I
probably don't expect one this season
the next season you have the nightfall
you will have the master nightmare hunts
because those seem to be staying around
cuz their shadow keep stuff and then
waste affects offensive and vex
offensive is even pinnacle right
so speaking of xfinity you know is it me
is that just a little too long right now
it started off cute and cool but now
it's like long well if you've run it
enough yeah it it doesn't get a miracle
the difficulty went up and now it takes
longer and I'm just like yo Deus I don't
know I guess the day the first week of
it I was like yeah this is cool it's fun
and then as it got harder and the bosses
were and I'm just like this is same boss
every time I know but it just feels like
it because the power creep up it just
takes so maybe I was with a bad group
maybe that's what it was I was like
believe me I've had some it's the last
boss I'll tell you how good the group is
like if they go for cycles yeah they're
they're not just sake shout out to the
blueberries I was waiting on my nerves I
think is taking a long time but okay
yeah cuz I've done it three if people
and also it's like what heavy interrupts
I'm in that last room I dumped all my
heavy em - dude have so much health oh
my god yes um I don't know he kind of
skewed like bounces to your level so he
shouldn't be that much different all
dumped my heavy I'll dump my super we'll
get him down for that first damaged
phase he'll move to the next one and
it's timed at least which is good you
can chunk him hard but yeah if I don't
get any heavy drama drops for the next -
I'm just pew pew and I'm for the next
two rounds and I'm just not helping I'm
like like so there's a reason it slows
down if you if your team's not getting
heavy ammo drops you're fine
it should be a 3-phase yeah it should be
I feel unfairly yeah but you're right
back to your initial point which I
interrupted you was which was you know
the facts offensive even though it's
being replaced that's currently not a
pinnacle source you're not correct yeah
so that kind of brings us to another
question of we know we'll have the
seasonals we'll get to those in a little
bit it could be a long point today but
we do like vex offensive and the moon
vex invasion is what we have this season
right now theoretically they know shadow
keeps gonna launch so the seasonal stuff
could be lighter because we have it
stacked with other content next season
in my mind next season like a vex
offensive mmm
not I don't know if that's enough mmm
what you mean language just if all we
get is like what I'm curious what they
do but if we like hey we get another I
mean just for I've heard this in other
places I'm not gonna claim to be the
original thinker of it but so let's go
say I'm the next one you're like okay
it's gonna be season of dawn we go back
to Mars they revamp escalation protocol
and then you get like something on Mars
as director to where there's a event
like that where you're facing something
okay so you have a new thing on the
planet and you have a new director
activity but that's mostly all you get
for the season besides they're like
sporadic like here's our tweak or here's
an exotic quest or whatever like do you
think that's enough for a season versus
I'm just I'm kind of curious because we
got I mean we had the forges we had the
menagerie we had reckoning which rating
everybody hates but content wise you
know was still he said my stuff but
where do you see like how much content
do you think you need in a season
because we got shadow keep and a season
but this season small versus all right
okay versus okay so kind of curious what
do you think is gonna be late
how much is enough how much do you think
season of dawn needs to feel good
take on it's one of those things where
this way I don't envy them from a
development standpoint you know cuz at
some point it's like okay how many like
I get them credit man for making
something like the menagerie making
something like that's a fence or
whatever you know to keep making new
activities for people to do that is not
an easy today and for us let's be honest
you know we've seen a lot oh you know
they're just recycling this or whatever
whatever you know I think for me I like
the VEX offensive menagerie trend that
we continue to get six-man match-made
activities right yes I want that
obviously in much as I'm you know much
as I'm selfish and I love raids we can't
get a raid every season I'm at that
point it has to be a gap between if we
want quality raise otherwise you're
gonna get apartment to be and the
Leviathan and Department to see like
we're gonna get them rail ace and you
know how I feel about raid layers so I
rather you don't even do that and you
just focus on other cool activities like
the dungeon our surprise we were getting
a dungeon to be honest this season in
conjunction with a raid and I'm saying
so I mean obvious we got it forsaken but
for sake was a bigger expense yeah so
large you know when I saw shadow key a
while this is a lot of content um I
think right now one new activity
obviously the only thing with a new
activity they can't base the entire
season around the one activity like they
did was season a drifter you have to
have multiple so at minimum I'm thinking
three you economy two to two to three to
keep the base engaged yep
or you bring back returning content that
is beloved that's just sitting on that
the world can't create policies happen
in crucible labs is there so I think
it's working but I just don't know when
there's one more that we know buddy and
I'm not even the biggest fan of it like
that should have sat on a bed spare only
bro is my spare only I had fun in that
I would have to pull out a controller
for that one yeah our only grow is sofa
like they've got stuff you know I'm
saying we still got fashion right
there's signo stuff that can revamp I'm
not worried I think what we gotta be
careful is if we're looking at it as if
shadow Keith ended right now and as if
it ended right now we like nothing it
was whack it's just that it's like he's
an event dying season of the entire
excuse me right so it's like it is just
it's just a ton more stuff that we
haven't seen they do the dungeon they do
the we see what happens storyline with
the final assault yeah yeah the final
saw distinct it seems like you got the
potential to be fire so I'm I think
right now two to three activities story
cohesion narrative stuff I think they're
fine
I think that is more than enough you
know saying that that's just my thing I
think we've got to be careful of whining
when we haven't seen all the chapters in
the book yet you know and that's totally
fair I'm actually just really curious
where they take the narrative piece with
all the connections because why did we
even go into the Garden of salvation
right right so is there like so is there
a point where the garden of salvation is
like is that like a yearly arc does that
get a bow tied on it and a pin and put
in that at that point does that ever
leave would you be maybe I ate itself
the raid like say like next year we got
space Doritos actually come in because I
mean the Garden of salvation we went to
the black garden in rare image like in
there and they sent us and they booted
us out of ship mm-hmm and then we go in
there and then we're fighting the vex
because they're coming in well we're
finishing the vex offensive like coming
right this season so our push to go it
was like our push to go in even into the
raid like right we're working on the vex
offensive the undying mind doing all
those things like right and then we're
going into the black guard to do all
this stuff like why are we still going
in there no no I was like and I want to
see the continuation yeah I honestly
don't I have a theory on it again I'm
pretty confident on theories right with
raids or the exception
narrative Li because you really can't
get rid of a raid you guys they like you
really can't like the raid is something
that is one of the pinnacle activities
in destiny right this is the stuff
they're making jackets for making pelts
for right that ain't going away so the
way I look at it it's like let's be real
you know we're still doing Leviathan
ain't no reason like that no no it is a
so I think raid is the exception where
it's just like hey if you want to do
this thing this callback activity that
was dope you doing but the way they're
looking at it is like the menagerie
things like the black armory things like
you don't say those things that are now
gonna have a narrative tie-in so we know
vex offense ain't no more vex gonna be
invading once we handle whatever we got
me kind of sad about the moon the moon
will be a little less fun without the
vex invasions yeah cuz those are cool
like like I've seen those before the vex
ones are those look yo and that's
skylight something like some aurora
borealis type situations I don't like
fire I like I like it yeah though I
don't know the future progression of the
seasons will be interesting so hey I
don't know we're in a decent spot we got
a long ways to go so it will be quite
the journey again for year three of
destiny - so it's been chatting loving
us of Rome would a David loving that Sol
talk I was talking oh they're also
dining on the space Doritos comment
supposed to read oh they love it for
that one I heard him say it once and I
guess not not think of them that way
shout out the Tefft I've heard it from
him - what I was like that is the
greatest representation of this new race
I am running with base Doritos and foggy
boys so yes salut all right well that is
probably as much as we can speculate
we'll know more as time comes but we
know the future is coming but right now
right around the corner the other future
is closed and we've got the festival of
the lost we've got our Halloween event
coming so you excited spooky time spooky
forest we are going back to the haunted
forest the tower will be redecorated
Tower it always looks cool when they
redecorate so we definitely got some
cool stuff there got some masks to earn
got a new weapon with random role
possibilities which is good they
haunted forest we got ever vs looking
just awesome stuff yeah
but overall like what do you I mean I'll
kind of cover some details here in a sec
but just overall like what do you think
of what you got to see so far for the
cosmetic stuff the suits look kind of
fun you know saying love skeleton those
are all amazing those accrual models are
just what is it like it was an ornament
fire
yeah girlfriend oh those that is super
unique that's something that really
stands out all shout out to our team and
these guys always knock it out the box
you know you got your braid tech
werewolf you know I like the little
theme with that you're gonna say to
where we yeah it's like the skeleton
suit for the gun cuz you can see like
the stock the bullets and all that stuff
inside it's cool and it was a unique
thing I I didn't mind it you know I
definitely I wish I could somehow get
horror story doubted I switched from
because they're busy that I lost my
horror story when I picked by leaning on
my PC character uh I see what um yeah be
we'll see what's going on with that
typical stuff I just want to know how
they handle drops you know I'm saying
what hot they're gonna be oh it's a
pinnacle as a powerful I say yeah
remember I told you I think Mach theory
might be the new Hustle is events and
they're gonna want us to tune in
remember his key word was like yo what
happened you believe when this happened
this week and that happened this week
and if you if you give a carat of
pinnacles in each of these little in
these events people will play first of
all I'm saying I do I don't know if
they're gonna do pinnacles there they
may speak whatever they may but I think
his idea of like you don't want to miss
it is like what happens when the VEX
offensive final assault happens as
opposed to like was the festival of lost
cool because
six-person match made not so much to
fail I mean it'd be nice if there was a
really cool way to go for one maybe like
what if there's some bounty with you
know levels of grind and completion yeah
yeah would give you a spend time in
there I'm curio Ward standpoint I'm
curious if it's a completely casual
event like
in the past and cosmetics and stuff that
or do they have also something for the
hardcore to kind of put a little carrot
on there besides just the weapon that
everybody wants to chase yeah so hmm I
guess we'll see so we've got Ava coming
she's gonna have your masquerader helmet
it's gonna be like 100 glimmer des
personnes this thing and then you're
gonna have the mask that you're gonna be
able to put on it and those are gonna be
I have a video up but it's you got what
looks like an acolyte a goblin The
Drifter heiress mythrax and then Callas
so which one is which what do you go in
Robert I'm rocking at calistri you're
going for ugly callous guy is hilarious
man I could listen to callous talk he
needs to just narrate stuff for me in
life like cows is he's hilarious do you
listen to this disco ball he's like yes
my shadow Oh keV yo he's he is so full
of himself it is just I could listen to
him for days he's just hilarious oh yeah
ball four cold cat
I was the heiress is cool they all are
good I like the master master she look
cool but just for me and my foolishness
I am going with caps thanks and then
once you pick your mask
you've got candy makes it sweet return
so you'll be able to spend out on
mystery grab bag so that's probably
gonna be where you get your random roles
on a whole bunch of crap so do you think
you think they bring it heiresses
raisins back yes it might be spoiled
raisins at this point but maybe that
will come back I'd be curious she's like
here's your raisins you're like I don't
want these yeah we've got the Bray Tech
werewolf legendary Auto rifle now this
thing if nothing else this is your
incentive and this is why I think
there's less of a pinnacle chance
because they are gonna give you this
there's a guaranteed fully mass work 950
weapon coming from just doing this
doesn't matter if you're 859 12 752
this thing will drop at 950 fully master
worked and then you can get random rolls
after that too so I will be curious if
the curated master worked role is like
kind of mid-level the way like the blast
furnace curator role is not actually the
one I want mm-hm
so I'll be kind of curious where they
stick the QD curated role versus the
random possibilities so
I don't know it looks pretty cool auto
rifles I was actually toying around with
one in crucible it's like they're
probably not gonna win in certain places
but they're feeling better than I
thought they would like auto rifles are
doing ok oh how nice of you to come
around on this I remember we had a
fierce who was go ahead a last word on
auto rifles discussion I'm just saying
like I had CDP I gotta see what I was
using which one have you been using cuz
I was using I have a half landy honestly
mm-hmm but it's ranges 94 so they're not
in the optimal place before with that
range though like that range I was
putting in some work though yeah like
that was actually recall direction of 70
if I put a mod in that one it would be
85 like dead center and recoil might
have to do that I don't know like the
cheetah had grown up today me I was like
ah here we go yeah the bhagavata because
they does like oh we really good no but
I like that you deal with see this is
the bad brake that got smashed in the
breakneck got like oh man they're still
good man it's still good it's like you
know but why did he get nerfed
like that and rhetorics both like cuz
I've heard people talking about it was
DCP or something they were talking about
between rederick still being overly good
versus like you know what I say recluse
and it was overly good and then read
Rick's and brake Nick or like worse than
before like they didn't need a nerf they
needed to get some helps and love and
now they're worse than they were like I
know pinnacles but those were not the
pinnacles people were worried about
though unfortunately because of what
they do I know what I did it I mean they
wanted huckleberry to be what outbreak
was they want the exotic to hold that
and as much as I look I don't like I
want to
Frederic's I mean to be still good don't
get me wrong but I see what you people
like it adversely it caught the wrath of
the rampage nerves and the you know
whatever nerve so you know it's it sucks
you know you still hope they would do
something to kind of make those two kind
of stand on their own I'm saying but I
still feel they're both good though
they're not terrible I use both
religiously and they're not terrible you
can still rock any good legendary
alternatives if you don't want to um you
know you waste your your kinetic spot
what what an exotic there's no DC it's
just you know we got our optimal builds
that's all yeah we'll get another auto
rifle we'll see how it is but mm-hmm
they're not all bad and some and that's
honestly why it's like sometimes there
are people bunnies pay like hey you need
auto rifles be like alright I'll hunt
for um for one let me pull it out so but
yep the haunted forest is going to be
fifteen minutes again see as far as you
can go 15 me this is kind of long by the
way it's kind of like that's a full
double gambit like long drawn-out match
yeah so that's full-on see how far you
can go and they said be aware of what
awaits you at the end do you remember
how it ended last year yeah I was gonna
say I was like I made a video about this
and I was like if you weren't there last
year I'm not gonna spoil it all I can
say is when you get to the end just be
careful be careful I'll watch your feet
watch your feet
yeah it's oh yeah watch your feet yeah
spooky well yeah that was kind of cool
I'll be curious if it's like a spooky
boss fight or if it's something just
kind of goofy like that at the end so
yeah I'll be curious how much they tweak
it cuz we had it before and hopefully
it's not exactly the same but the ever
verse is absolutely gonna crush it this
time around I'm pretty sure and I did
see confirmed on reddit everything will
at some point cycle through four bright
dust everything will eventually come
through four bright dust so if you want
the broomstick hmm if you want the bat
ship if you want the tomb stone emote
that is the one everyone is going to buy
those fire you don't need to troll you
don't need to t-bag anymore you'll just
tombstone the crap out of them just
thump top of tombstone down on their
head I think that's what everybody's
gonna do is like you don't need to
teabag anymore the real peace
we'll put the tombstone down oh yeah a
tombstone is just so disrespectful Aries
yes that one's that's awesome so I'm
hoping that cuz I I don't see teabags
that often but when I do I'm like man
you are it's just so immature it's
ridiculous I can't stay in them but the
ghosts are awesome you got the pumpkin
you've got the bat go she'll looks goofy
like a four-year-old made it it's
awesome
yes and I'm actually kind of wondered
about those ornaments like the jack o
lantern and the omnigul ornament mm-hmm
cuz you could just be in crucible and
have this big giant like I don't know if
the idea to have a big target but like
you could just have an omnigul ornament
all the time actually kind of like the
idea of just like armor ornaments that
you can get from a season that's
actually kind of cool so mm-hmm
and then to go with those we have the
skeleton suits these are cool looks like
the yellow what looks like and I can't
see the blue one so somebody will have
to like help me if they can figure it
out the yellow one looks like callous
like skeleton Anna and the red one looks
like gall kinda sorta yes I can't tell
what the blue one is out what the blue
one is yeah I don't know I don't know it
looks like it's got a different bone
structure though so I don't know maybe
it's like a knight or but like if I can
wear those and the shoulder pads too
alone like fine blocky black shoulder
pads like yeah I might be wearing those
I'll be on that's an outfit yeah that's
definitely in one lasso that that puts
puts any worry of it hey do we need new
stuff if they keep bringing some
ornaments like this keep them going so
that's pretty cool shoutouts in a
broomstick though dude that looks barrel
and that's straight up the like Harry
Potter fire bolt 3000 or whatever that
things called I forget exactly because
broomstick is really cool and then of
course the tombstone emote at the end
but a couple things when it comes to
this event if you guys are listening I
made a note to copy these as well you do
have to be seven a seventy or your new
light player 750 or if you're a normal
just veteran player you can do the
haunted forest with matchmaking or
without so you have the preference oh
nice nice so you can go solo or pre-made
if you want to if you just want a to man
it just for fun or if you just you know
don't have anybody you got matchmaking
it's still sitting there for you
we're gonna have our two weeklies four
dailies additional bounties you got your
masks yeah we're gonna have three
different mods and they you've got
higher purpose vampiric touch and
energetic assassin so probably one of
the bottom two sounds good because
getting health on kill is always a good
thing and then the energetic assassin is
like significant increased damage
against errors that's probably always
gonna be big they did make know one of
the tooltips on the mods is not quite
correct so just make the note that they
just kind of activate when they're
equipped they don't have anything crazy
and then they've got some triumphs on
there as well they did state and that's
the only thing I want kind of blown
through this for this reason when it
comes to the tramps if you unlock a
triumph click on it before the season's
over otherwise it is going away you will
lose it that is just one big thing going
on make sure to make note of self yeah
big deal now one is big but yeah I mean
festival seems like it'll be cool a
Halloween event but we've also got some
other stuff going on this week yeah yeah
so dungeon that's my worries okay no
wait and they didn't tell us a damn
thing about it they're like a new
dungeon is opening up in willing fire
teams or brave guardians who want to
tackle it alone speak with Eris she
knows the way she knows and that's all
we get I'm like you should love it you
should love I know believe me don't you
start don't you start miss no I'm not no
no no not too much
no no I'm not getting mad I'm just like
I just like Tuesday can't get here soon
enough that's all like I don't want to
know they give us all we've seen is this
one picture of this like one hallway
thing and that's all we've seen and I
just love that Scarlett Keith feel the
Reds in it just fits it couldn't have
more of a contrast to the other dungeon
yeah that's why I think imma be a fair
modest already just because I know my
brother panic I know my brother well he
can't he can't stand the ascendant role
yeah oh so the black in the black and
away a black black and why he's like you
know like the depth and textures and
stuff like that he's just like not a fan
of just how it looks and he's just like
he'll probably like this one more even
if he gets like his butt kicked in it
he's like I'm still probably gonna like
it more so yeah it is
the ascendant room is cool it's just I
guess it just wore on me after a while
like when I first saw it as a harness is
so dope like witnessing it realm is just
but you got the cold space feel you
don't saying but like this man it is
this looks like a dungeon let's be more
like this more this looks like a hive
dungeon a hive dungeon like this this
looks fine I cannot wait
looks like platforms making a fire crazy
yes yeah we fired us
I needed that man just boombastic
looking things to fight and can't wait
can't wait on Tuesday I'm hoping it's
not like a 980 dungeon cuz that's gonna
hurt so if it's like 950 I will be
trying it on my own try it solo Jesus do
I like so I've ruined the experience
like get some friends damnit I give you
credit a go face well that's what you do
that's what you do Dobby that is your
calling card Who am I to stop your fun
of the solo mastery the nightfall
Shattuck grown soloist himself
lordy bonta's so I mean look do what you
do i there is no way I'm stepping foot
in this overlay I'm calling to friends
we are not going into this nightmare
alone I no no no no yeah I got I got a
buddy out there dramatic you say so to
salute nothing else is just like I want
to explore it part of it yeah like I
don't know that ogre fight mmm my god
mm-hmm
that ogre fight ruined me for a while
learning that one solo died so many
times like once I kind of got though
like especially once I knew I could do a
damage cycle then it was just not dying
there was such tight corners when I was
setting everything up for like my
rotation it was just like and it's just
like a crap death and I was like I'm
just like he's like standing nope yeah
I'm okay he knows where I'm supposed to
be where what's going on where to put I
spent way too much time and I could draw
you a damn map like go with you actually
a machine in there like you don't you
it's it's verbal muscle memory for you
like like literally I'm sitting in my
own damn you know okay cool cool fine
I'm just gonna shut up get in the
backpack and just tell me where he way
to go yeah and the whistles like
esoteric scan clear with one hand behind
his back and he's gonna be using his
mouth with his with his nose or
something and clicking on enemies and
wishful shout out the esotery he and I'm
convinced the man is not human that are
we gonna find out the secret of esoteric
his Android is a computation he's an
algorithm esoteric the obvious Julian
but I've that bad does things that I've
just like yeah god bless I don't know
how that's why I was like somebody up in
the comments was like hey did you retire
solar night in Fell's I'm like no
haven't done any I just haven't been
high enough to run the solos yet so I
kind of wanted to be at a comfortable
place to do that but yeah I got to get
back into those but yeah he think he did
solo 980 already or what dude oh Lord
him Slayer age both of those guys do
stuff that's beyond me savage you know
yeah so that's coming next week and I
could not be more pumped for that one
don't know much tune in and see so you
may have you don't have love items bar
theater knows where I I started I
started to acquire I'm not gonna like
the second the third step where I know
what the final thing is cuz I shout out
to my squad um some co-workers of mine I
find out they had destiny and shots a
rack team but that yeah they're dumb
apparently they will deal working on the
final step so I was just happened to be
on one day let's go car can you help me
out and I'm like alright cool it I'm
like so what's funny is I said hey what
do I need should I be coming in super
sweaty
you know optimal load out and he's like
oh what are you working on I'm actually
I'm on a second step which is like the
bow kills because I dusted off lemon Ark
and I'm alright let me get that going
man that strike right there was not
casual like it was like the end point
the innocent comes like the end is the
only thing with know the orbital drops
coming down on you and they spawn ants
and I'm in there with this stupid
loadout that I'm not really supposed to
does not optimal you guys I mean
obviously I could change it at any point
which I did but I was just like yeah
this thing it was challenging I would
just say like I was I was surprised it
was it was definitely more challenging
so I definitely get it
I saw your tape I believe you put a
video up on it or something like that
and I saw another clip of it lots of my
boy oh he's one of my writers was gaming
down there a bob dunne he's on
PlayStation and he had it he showed me I
was like how you like him and show me a
clip of him like melting like some named
yellow bar and I'm like man acting like
strong so now that you got it how you
feeling about it
leviathans breath what's up it is a big
big boy it is a big boat dude oh my gosh
thirteen-hundred draw time okay I'm here
it's like in it oh no it's not think
it's flu like there's some there's some
power behind now it hits pretty hard
mm-hmm so for you get Tim in reserve or
total I guess okay Tim if you throw blow
reserves on you can do double bow
reserves you can go to 11 and 12 if you
do that okay I tested that it hits hard
it really does like the hit and
explosion both combined for a lot of
damage I was testing it in tribute all
which is a nice place right so I tested
in there it's hard the explosions kind
of sketchy like it's not reliable
um but overall like it hits pretty hard
you've got a longbow draw time but if
it's there mm-hmm it's not bad like it's
it's like a step below sleeper really
long charge time yeah pretty solid yet
when it does you know you got reflection
versus kind of explosion a little change
up there but overall pretty similar to
that is probably the best way I can
phrase it yeah it's not gonna go through
but I mean takes a while to charge up
hits pretty hard decent ammo similar
amount like you
probably use like couple more rounds to
balance out I think the damage
difference and the lack of reflection as
well so stuff like you could I think you
could use a little balanced a little
more ammo probably just like if there's
a catalyst like bring the draw time down
something like those type of tweaks
would be nice and I still don't think it
would be broken in PvP shout out to the
people who made those videos already
that thing will one-shot supers Wow yep
okay yeah so if you get heavy ammo you
can smash a super in the face if you can
actually hit it and he goes bye-bye
I'm pretty sure it kills just about
everything - I know the highest
Brazilians are highest armor level I
guess when you're in your super is like
yeah invisible spectral yeah that's the
hardest one to kill and I think it even
can kill that if not I know it kills
everything else but it'll kill it you
can't see the guy so good luck but yeah
you can you can kill a lot of stuff with
that thing and I think you get like
three or four shots with it - in PvP oh
yeah you just you get some out yeah you
get some shots good ain't one of that
like one or two bit like I used to do
okay cool no it's kind of fun yeah you
will stagger now this is where I'm kind
of wondering about xenophanes because we
got Ariana's Val yes which is a barrier
breaker then this one is an unstoppable
boom and then we have Zeno phage coming
I'm like is that going to be overload
are they gonna do how to be right are
they're gonna do exotics that kind of
tie into those new mod effects mmm I
would think so it would make them
valuable in the season you know and then
narrative Lee it's what is it they were
like wait we went to ban Chi something
like you know something to help you out
during this whole offensive I still
don't see how the tie is to if you read
the law on the bow it's like calluses
right so I'm a middle of Athens breath I
would imagine it is yeah that's callous
flavor text when you melt at the thing
so I guess I'm just it just feels like
you know more armory stuff to kind of
help us you know against this whole vex
offensive thing and I did like that they
start to request a little Banshee thing
finding the entrance yes around the
tower that's kind of fun I started that
off
you know kind of thing so you know III
like it you know I think it is it will
tie in to this new thing that they're
doing which I do like I really do like
the champions I do like that you know
you have to have it's something cool
what I do a knife fall and it's like oh
man who's got the overload rounds and
who's got you know I'm saying because
these enemies are not gonna go down to
those those unstoppable ogres if you did
they do
they literally build us up if you don't
have that thing you're like oh my likes
I'll run into like at 9:29 fall and it
feels like nobody else's got that
overload of like holding a hand cannon
hole yes get the shimmer stop moving
buddy boom and then Friday they kill him
but it's like if I don't pull that out
ice or sometimes people don't go in load
it the right way
right wait guys are just running rampant
smashing everybody was like anybody know
okay I'll do it fine like I go in there
with my only issue is like your farthest
range with all those modded weapons is a
damn Auto rifle yeah cuz usually it's
typically been over it's been
unstoppable and barrier a lot I haven't
seen overload very often because I think
that's typically and stuff we haven't
seen so the overload you can use a bow
on technically or an auto but man ought
it was like your typical longest range
for those things you got to be you got
to be a little snuggly with those
baddies you're like I don't want to be
snuggly like you man I mean it just adds
a fun dynamic to like I said doing
strikes during the night falls and stuff
like that I really enjoy and then that
little thing at the end when you to be
honest I really wasn't you know last
season the last I just hasn't been to a
night falls and I will say shadow keep
brought it back for me because one the
rewards be the reward to the higher the
level the more credit you get and then
also that little carrot ice tavin got my
four hundred thousand oh man I've come
close so many times
dude this week I ran I know I want to
try with a group that actually like I
want to try with a group together cuz at
nine twenty making like 95 and 94 got
six I was right there I'm like
come on like I think with a good team
like maybe some more tethers pairing up
together like mm-hmm I don't feel like
I'm missing that many new enemies Mosley
Levesque I'm loose like absolutely not
have it bro and I keep I'm making sure
I'm killing all the champions I'm not
crazy
like I'm not getting me you're really
gonna make me go do a 950 just for that
cuz like yeah I know some people said
it's like it's possible but it is hard
to do it's just and I don't even and I
think you could run maybe a little
faster but I don't think I was even
short on time one time like me either
yeah I don't know think I was very
efficient no no and are we I had a good
team oranjee I think it's what you said
I think everybody used master work
weapons every ball their pairs are there
like chained supers like modal's the
coordination I think it definitely is
what you said I think it's talk they're
forcing the higher non match made
version to really to get it man I'm just
like Tam I haven't yosh out the booty
you guys did it with 9:50 okay so you
haven't done the 950 yet and I got ya I
might have to do that I'm a jumping
which are you you and Cyn man I'd to
jump in there which at some point I was
gonna bread yeah yeah oh yeah challenge
on this weekend
we got a little off track sorry
everybody guess we did but for
everything else this weekend we got the
dungeon we also have crucible getting
this have some control let me gratis
well let me go yes get it sir get that
crucible you know momentum next week
lord shaxx is mixing things up in the
crucible with a new mode called momentum
control while mayhem put focus on supers
momentum shifts your focus to gameplay
this is a fast paper here on Oh gun play
this is a fast-paced hair on fire
experience with the lift Ally of all
weapons have been cranked to 11 you
incentivize to be aggressive as you
defeat other Guardians to earn charge
melee these grenades and supers here's a
quick rundown of what - you're hilarious
right buddy what to expect
stick respawning times out of a fight no
problem drop back in immediately weapon
damage increased higher combat lifts
Ally everything in your arsenal is a
contender that's cuz it's gonna be like
gold and I like Golden Gun mode or
something like everything gonna be like
a one shot doesn't matter if it's a
peashooter sidearm who knows like
interesting ability regen requires
effort defeat enemy players to charge
your melee grenade and super so what do
we start off with nothing no tracker
yeah snow tracker sneak around your
enemies for sweet snow track control via
app control zones capture faster and
grant more bonus points per kill
supercharged supers increased damage
resist in super means you become the
1000 pound grant gorilla be careful
because heavy weapons will put you down
quickly so there's the counter tap and
the heaviest of em oh no this each
favorite increased heavy ammo respawn a
drop about so they said many of us have
been play testing this have compared it
to the classic halo custom game SWAT
from nest but for destiny we've done a
lot of trying out different weapons and
seeing how they behave in this heavily
modified sandbox of a mode momentum will
be the feature 66 rotating playlists
during festival of the loss will be
monitoring the community's response to
see what when we want to bring it back
so eat where you at with the momentum
sounds fun
it really does like more emphasis on
gunplay a little more lethality they're
having to earn supers mean they're not
gonna be coming up as often I was all
good until all the heavy like yeah I was
good like dolls like if people just run
around machine guns a grenade launcher
the whole time that's just that's a
different type of mayhem I want like you
know autos and snipers and Scouts I want
those things to be the focus I'd love
like the top two slots to be the focus
so hopefully heavy doesn't kind of break
it too much I do like having to earn
supers but when you get it like you're a
beefy you are you are gonna be force to
be reckoned with heavy a counter to that
so it's not
bad thing but I mean a lot less
abilities I like it I do I think that's
that's gonna change up kind of how it
feels for sure I'll be very very curious
how this plays I'm quite intrigued
yeah the whole thing about earning
abilities through killing that's that
that's a unique twist
that's like Call of Duty killstreaks oh
yeah totally different feel for destiny
instant respawn time so that's gonna be
crazy
just BAM back in the game I'm worried
about some you know spawning trapping
and you know we got to see a task on go
you know so we got to be careful but um
yeah we'll see we see increased heavy
amount you know that's the only thing
that seems a little oxy you know they
say hey we're gonna focus more on
comfort but you giving out a whole bunch
of heavy you know we'll see how that
that play out but overall though it
sounds fun yes yeah so I don't know what
um I can't even say your name sugar
seeds shegaon mm-hmm saying shoddy apes
will still rule and I was like I may be
wrong but I don't leave you think you're
gonna be able to get close enough to
shotgun anybody close enough if
everything like the palette II like if
submachine guns are gonna kill you
that's about as close as you'll get but
autos will probably like free tap you
from range mm yeah he's got all the
scouts are to tapping out there I will
say this though he's only right from the
standpoint because of no radar that's
your guys a camping dudes are being in
the corner camping you know getting a
giant sort of no read off of show
mmm-hmm I do think recluse will
definitely still be popular yes until
shuts them down yes indeed all the
fusions all of whoop masters will be out
there sir
we got loops and loops in this game you
guys are you guys it kind of killing me
but it's fine you I don't know overall I
think it's cool it's nice to see them
bring a new mode into the game I just
hope it's not one of those where it's
like it's really well right now and
everybody likes it and we don't see it
for six months it's been longer than
that it's been longer today but it was
it like if people enjoy it be like okay
it's just in the rotation now just once
a month or something just if people
enjoy it please listen and please keep
it around it's just rather it's somewhat
frustrating when we don't when the
community does actually favor stuff like
they through scorch Hopa scorch in like
last week or something
like we haven't seen that in so long but
every so often it's just kind of funny
so it's fun man I agree uh and then so
yeah next week's gonna be crazy so we've
got momentum Control Festival lost you
got uh all that stuff you got the
dungeon coming this will be going on
this will pretty much be the next three
weeks to fill our time before the final
assault and then also on top of that we
also have the joys a bunch of doing good
things for the world so game to give
charity events so if you guys are in
chat right now I've got a link set up
for you guys to be able to donate all of
these will count so you guys can do this
however you're going for so that's the
link you guys that's just I set one up
for us that we can use and it's just a
link that's out there but it is an
awesome one that they're doing so what
they do is a program called iPads for
kids and it's for the Children's Miracle
Network it's all the children's
hospitals around the country they
started with one up in Seattle they've
got trying to remember like hundreds if
not thousands of iPads in that hospital
for kids all around the country they've
expanded multiple hospitals they have
hospitals reaching out to them there's
like an eight minute video out there
about the thing it's really cool and it
just helps win and kids are going to
these hospitals
none of these are great situations but
they see the iPad they can have a fun
distraction and it's a really cool thing
so this is their charity fundraiser for
this event
100% of the proceeds are going to game
to give so it's all going towards this
cause and just want to shout out so you
can sign up actually did yesterday to
put this thing together so you can
stream and I'll be setting up like
streams maybe Tuesday when I do the
dungeon or something like that from
October 24th yesterday through November
10th and then if you do actually
streaming if you do fundraising
milestones you have a chance to get some
stuff as well but for you guys if you
donate you got a couple options you $10
donation will get you the new mist
blossoms eat Amblin pretty cool little
emblem so it kind of a flower to it but
a decent aesthetic in the background $50
donation will earn you the mist blossoms
emblem and our first ever charity ghosts
so it's a gilded shell exotic ghosts so
exotic ghosts but basically it's like an
ornate gold kind of ornamental structure
around the center go
it's pretty cool it's got the little
heart in the middle so it is that's a
bunch of foundation that's really
awesome and then if you go big for a
hundred bucks you'll earn both of the
items above and be entered to win an
item from the Bungie price pool so you
can actually get the vinyl replica of
that Ghost you can get a couple of those
it's like those what are they two or
three hundred dollar figurines like the
Titan the warlock you get the anthology
it looks like a chess set a giant ax
which is what everybody would want you
got like the vinyl soundtracks just some
really really cool stuff and it's all
that's a chance to win but I mean it's
all going to to charity so hundred
percent of the donations go to charity
so again at least ten bucks
get yourself an emblem if you want the
goes it's fifty help support the cause I
mean watch the video if you watch the
video and don't want it like you know
donate all the money in your wallet and
crazy so cool so once again bungee out
here doing great things just for the
world outside of making games that we
lose ourselves in so yes sir
definitely wanted to shout that one out
so it is between now and November 10th
so don't sit on it you got about 15 16
days definitely make sure you guys are
getting you're giving your time in there
already donated 50 that's awesome yep
awesome awesome
keep it going yes so for you guys that
somehow this is the weirdest thing okay
I will tell you guys like when we do a
podcast if I feel like hey we have like
16 topics to go over we've got a guess
like I somehow get on the mission and we
like we still get on decent talks and
what we like plow through the topics in
like 90 minutes and then we'll have like
nothing to talk about on a week and it's
like two hours and 15 minutes yeah I got
a render this video and we and I'm like
so okay that's just like a just a
realistic piece for fees like podcasting
is a weird sometimes it goes long
sometimes it goes oddly succinct in
short so it was one of those weird ducks
for sure mm-hmm but yeah is there
anything I mean anything else the touch
was um yeah I was like I'm missing
something
I was gonna say we're gonna touch the I
know they talked about the
the fashion thing which was which was
cool oh yeah I had the the titles did we
talk about the titles with the how like
how did I like how you're thinking about
handling the triumphs and with the yes I
actually didn't get down there you want
to touch on that cuz I actually totally
forgot about I knew there was more so
yeah it's just pretty much um you know
the way they actually I was gonna ask
you was gonna actually defer to you
could you the one that has all the
triumphs you knows that I've liked the
five so yeah like a lot like I have I
just lazy I just gotta get them done I
just want on dying just because of that
word underneath your name is like just
beyond like it does he I'm dying
I would love it if it said the undying
they'd be even better but it's like I
mean we are Guardians hopefully we
weren't dying but just the like the
wording like shadow was a cool one for
ninja like it's a hard one to get but
shadow would be a cool one for you to
have but like would be legit like I was
shadowing laxman I really won't
blacksmith bad that was one of my
brother one and then he saw you how to
do a perfect great no it's just like
dude I want to get I gotta get his
scourge man I gotta get in it yeah well
I gotta get some of those old armor mods
too
those are things ya don't I almost leap
on those old raids you got mod sitting
out there possibly wait Laura Mars I
what threat detected I want an Okie
shout out - definitely Gary who cannot
give an up do you have you seen these
tweets uh there was some guy I don't
know what he's up to how many runs oh I
think he's like 12 14
oh no there was a guy who literally had
on he had a cross-stitch made a hundred
plus runs without anarchy damned if he
just got it he got it out like 112 or
something but he literally had like a
cross-stitch picture on his desk and
then he finally put a picture below of
it was just like a hundred plus without
that's like I mean winded skirts come
out back in January December that was
black armor every black armor yeah
sometimes that week like dude the man
he's missed them all actually just to
summarize you know I'm saying as far as
you know for people like me who there's
some old titles and stuff that I want
and try them stuff break this down
explain to me how this is going to work
move uh so most of the time when you
guys have your triumphs when you go to
you know your inventory go to try them
screen
previously in year two it was like an
on-off switch there wasn't a lot of like
in-between or progress it was just did
you accomplish said tasks click on it
you got it
some had score or some didn't I still
for the boggle to my mind that the solo
flawless shatter throne does not have
points attached to it I was that should
be worth like a thousand but I digress
um but they said they triumph now have
tears so you'll have different levels of
them and then they'll kind of unlock the
next series you get to it so for example
season eight power bonus triumph it has
three tiers and the first tier you need
to gain five bonus power from the
artifacts once you do you'll get ten
points from the triumph score so it just
gives you a little more progression of
score so you seen triumphs more often
basically they're giving you that little
dopamine fix of like oh I didn't like
who I did something and they're doing it
more frequently so you might go click on
and that bar might go a third you're
like why am i click oh and now it's just
you're gonna see progress as opposed to
full completion on these but some of
them they also went back and revamped I
feel like they gave you more stuff to
work on you'll actually see your
progress which is kind of annoying when
you see hey this triumph I have three
hundred eighty four percent on this
thing and I'm twelve percent here huh
somebody didn't balance this quite
correctly but those are there mmm so the
triumph so like they're gonna give you
more tears for pursuits they're gonna
give you seasonal stuff to do and then
everyone has a chance to show their
stuff off okay so but the question I
have now is what about a guy like me who
there are some because the vibe I'm
getting is that you know there are
limited time trying dying the both the
title that you can attach to yourself
the badge down there and also the
triumphs that are available December
11th
they be gone away so my question though
is what about a guy like me like say for
example I really wanted you know nose to
the grindstone on blacksmith or you know
shadow or whatever whatever you know is
it I have they are they're gonna make a
determination with every single older
season that is going to go away at some
point like how are they how do you think
they're gonna handle
is my question though they said the
decisions pre shall keep triumphs that
no longer require effort can't be earned
after season seven so that was four like
new light players stuff like that if it
didn't have effort like logging in
getting to level 50 well everybody's a
little 50 now getting to seventh late
they got rid of some of those right
seasonal triumphs will have a score if
you miss triumphs during season of
undying you may not be able to max out
your score so they are actually giving
you an option if you do miss and you
love that like you want to be like Teddy
one of the friends right podcast like it
has like max triumph score which is just
insane if you miss a season you might
not be able to get it all but the old
stuff isn't going away at least I
haven't said it yet I mean I would
assume at a minimum you have till year
four okay
like I don't think that stuff is going
anywhere so if you do want to go for
blacksmith if you don't do like the year
1 and year 2 content I feel like is
there they kind of moved some stuff
around like I know people have given
them feedback about say the forge is
being able to pick which four to run one
a run as opposed to waiting for the
daily rotation scourge of the past last
wish
dreaming city all that stuff still going
to be there so if you're working on
curse breaker Chronicle or those types
of things you can still go for them to
my understanding at least for a while
I don't think those are going away I
think season of the undying you might be
like undying dawn like dawn might be a
seasonal thing where there's like score
that you can earn there's a title you
can earn but if you don't get them they
go bye-bye
gotcha I think that's the temporary
nature of those at least that's my
understanding if not somebody's please
correct me but that's at least guy you
to triumph guys what is your triumph
score you're probably not that far off
I don't even you know what's funny you
know it's pathetic
I don't even check it and let's it's
mandatory to complete some aspect of a
quest like you know what I had that was
forced like with lightens up go clear
the trailer or something I was like why
isn't it giving it to me oh I didn't
good
I don't even be in there I'm be honest I
don't I'm not in there that's like one
of those weird OCD things that I see it
I gotta go click on it yeah because you
see the little plus on
go check that box a with my damn
collections - mm-hmm I could get that
some additional focusing on pursuits in
I mean I don't worry about the triumphs
as much I'd say more the titles would be
probably where I look more yes
so like the undying title it's like okay
so go in here I need to use like hand
cannons and bows a lot so that type of
stuff 92 km from attic down you are
I think 93 was towards the top I'm sure
it bumped up some but me and I'm like 74
you kickin my button so oh yeah it's
what I like though it's it's a cool
grind for the hardcore and I think
titles is a really cool addition I
really do enjoy it it is dope I don't
know which one I'm kind of in Chile I'm
probably closest to I'm very close to
unbroken I think I'm like maybe one or
two away yeah you can be one away from
unbroken but that's the hardest one to
get you have to get legend in three
different seasons oh I only got it in
like you know did you like 50 that's
what you have to get that three times
you have to get got yeah okay it's rough
that's what I'm like I'm like uh I think
I haven't used I have two left on
unbroken and cuz it's just you need play
enough crucible you get there go look at
the shoe you have to do they're the
hardest ones that's why I like those
were not broken more power to your pilot
so it'd be like I'd have to start now
and they'd be done at season 11 it's
just to get unbroken just think you know
broke yeah yeah back Smith it is
hopefully I can get some drops and it
likes that's what you're always regim
curse breaker chronicler what what do
you have you said you have won one title
most of 100 titles bro I have nothing
III what it is I don't pay attention I'm
not I should be in there actively trying
to have a load out or do whatever it is
they want and I just like I get so
caught up with other things I get caught
up with my weapon pursuit grind
and that kind of thing on my loadouts
and you know if it's a weapon
I'll get crazy for it but as far as like
hey do this and run around the world and
get that and okay that's for you guys
showoff
I'm content with my basic me over here
they got a lloyd title they ever come up
with something like that like their Lord
yeah iron Lord oh I mean I mean all the
way I'm committed just like Lord you're
like I have this have to have it the
world goes away until this is listen I
spent $10 for that emote damn it when he
put the thing down
I spent my $10 happily so yeah that that
would be something what was that
dramatic was saying what seals do I have
I have
mm xix chronicler dredgen mmm
curse breaker and what is the like
normal collections one that I had to do
all the DMR stuff for you know what I'm
talking about it's yeah it's it's not
the why'd you talk about the one here
what is it Wayfarer yeah that one wait
wait for it when we got to go get the
collection stuff and you have a wafer
yeah so just yeah travel travel around
space and duel shall rounds I used to do
stuff do stuff yep so yeah Wayfarer
chronicler chronicler was just like
hardest part was just time and dreaming
city just waiting for those weeks mm-hmm
and then curse breaker just shooting all
the eggs you guys ever need eight videos
I probably have some copies of every
video it's like people like I'm glad you
still make these I'm like you could just
like I have been doing this for a long
time so yeah there's like probably ten
copies of everyone out there but they're
there thousand YouTube videos plus later
those are some those are some filler but
there there you go people still watch
them even though I had been watching
them less I will say like as well but
that's for this week somehow we like
burned through all the stuff they got
some like you can change subtitle text
size and color if you want to use a
little quality life thing for that type
of stuff they do the fashion show slowly
mm-hmm and
interesting the honorable mentioned I
saw that one pop-up and I thought he got
something just like Vaughn there's your
skittle warlock right there
that guy is absolutely skittle colored
he he's ready for future walk oh he's
not yeah his application is in and
pending right now shoutouts an angel
Montero for that one yeah shoutout to
and this lonely I'll touch this lasting
is very brief which was the UM forges
and festival because shout out to my boy
poor Lord addict man he didn't get he
never grinded Izanagi he wasn't around
he wants this gun so bad yo destiny
community y'all bad y'all here lfg yeah
out here is a naughty shaming people we
are we are we gal yeah it's back in full
force
he must have izanagi's yo booted from LF
G's with the lad they wouldn't say what
do you got he's like well I got that
even if you had a whispered a like no is
it not
yo it's bad it's bad so I feel bad
because he's been really trying because
now the way the for just set up you
can't go to the forge anytime you want
because now it's on he literally has to
log in every day on a reset to hope he
gets the forge he wants then gets the
key mold and all that other stuff then
it's a glitch with the key mold that was
preventing he's so frustrated with not
getting izanagi and shout out to Destin
if a Bungie for finally resolving some
of these issues that a lot of people who
never grind it you know I'm saying so
the first thing they're gonna resolve an
issue that prevented veterans from
unlocking at the forge and completing
the mysterious box quest for izanagi
burden they resolved an issue that
prevented players from abandoning the
mystery box quest for izanagi and they
also and the exodus black destination
quest they talked about from failsafe
and a couple other little quality of
life stuff but the main thing was the
the black Forge mysterious box stuff
that's killing a lot of people with
glitter and yeah if you don't have it
that stunt your progress to getting that
thing done man so I am trying to Brian
get your I do to say I am so glad I
crime
like at the end of uh what is it uh
season ah places like yo you still
playing I noticed you playing a lot I
was grinding for that I am so that right
I don't want to know what Garden of
salvation and fighting Megatron is
without that you know I'm saying and
it's just such a such a great gun so
yeah shout out to those guys help is on
the way with update two point six point
one and D unwell mmm that's why you
wouldn't know I mean that's a big one
though because this is Nagi says right
now sitting pretty powerful when you
like man you hit that four shot just
like ii ii ii ii ii ii ii ii ii ii ii
done like damn i mean when we jumped in
the raid was scary shot out to him when
he pulled us through like we jumped in
that first time just cuz we had that and
we were running in together literally we
did half damage half me first damage fit
with santana and everybody's on this
shot it's it's beastly it is absolute
monster so you shot the do mental I
missed a forge content yeah it's the
thing is it's dream it's more
streamlined this way but a couple of
steps are a little harder for the guys
that didn't do it the traditional way
but there are steps that we had to do
like unlocking Niobe labs and a lot of
the foolishness that was that they get
to avoid there's certain stuff that
we're knowing oh yeah they really get to
avoid so it's it's a given a you know
take but if you got your Izanagi
get you catalysts get that heroic
menagerie get that damn catalysts don't
damnit
no I didn't do the heroic I did the
heroic and I my chalice wasn't finished
I what does that thing do I always
forget all right so you this is more
damage on the stack Yoda honed ages it's
it's ignorant it even more powerful even
yes oh my god that even seeing folk
boy getting me let me know when you I
love I love all menagerie so you let me
know when you need to act
yeah I need a red menagerie a little bit
get a couple mods from there you know
some stuff but I've just been trying to
level man that's all I've been trying to
do I'll just like get my character level
please get that catalyst it is a huge
difference huge difference please you
wrote you write a now run around with a
half
happy half gun didn't quite get it Ennis
bacon in there so cook that thing up man
that's not again Oh your chalice was
full and you finish for her oak you get
it that's all
guarantee drop with a perfected chalice
we'll make sure every node that's but
that's been done it's just I didn't have
it done when her it's not watched God
and then that's like the only time I
really did it so yeah I just need to
tell ya please like I said I definitely
call me I love that activity plus I
would get some mods if I running with
you so yeah if you do it so I know I'm
tapping I'm excited damn it I'm excited
so I hit the desk I love it but yo
please get that joint um when you do it
call your boy I've gotta get it now love
that activity of it love I can do that
see if we can find people who still want
to run that thing but shoutouts all you
guys out there so yeah well man this has
been a fun one Thank You Chet you guys
have been absolutely amazing this
morning so don't forget if you're
looking for the charity link I will put
it I will paint it to my Twitter right
now so you guys can definitely help out
the iPads for kids
I know multiple people probably have
them but you haven't donated definitely
look on donating go through the link on
my Twitter so you guys can go there and
help them help the kids I mean that is
probably one of the biggest ones like
we're leveling we're playing we're
having fun I'll put the ones who aren't
having that much fun right now that's
that's a big one right now so how does
where I think we will wrap this thing up
you guys have been awesome today
absolutely freaking amazing thank you
very much I will do my wrap in a second
but yeah we wrap it up what do you got
sir know what it is with me like I said
our podcast returns again on Sunday 11
a.m. Eastern Football friendly time and
you never supposed to guess she's all
somebody older veteran in the community
good friend mojo blue you know I'm
saying so he's a hardcore gamer we're
gonna be talking about everything that's
going on with these PlayStation 5 specs
that's released you know what's going on
with dad we're gonna talk some outer
worlds that's a big one going on a
community as well as are all the latest
in gaming with the rest of the Lords
Lord addict Lord King Lord sovereign we
will be there getting lemonade
em and of course on the iron Lords
podcast channel you can also check out
right now currently up if you're in the
statues check out king of the statutes
my boy Kings got another fantastic piece
I believe it is it for the Marvel fans
if you remember the Planet Hulk
storyline catch daddy's got gladiator
Hulk up there looking phenomenal and
yeah man and of course Lords of gaming
that net all the great articles
describes in the room putting up good
content man please check that stuff out
really put in a lot of hard work with a
and I love you guys support the the site
if you can and of course you know every
Friday that morning one of the best
destiny podcasts out here that last
world at the campfire with my boy II you
already know Friday 9:00 a.m.
generally generally not a ish you don't
start late apparently ish we do but yeah
so that's salute man who did it chat
everybody in here having fun listen to
me tapped a desk and drive me crazy yeah
I know you love it there's there's a
shirt and also a movie you're killing me
smells like you are just killing me
there so alright for me to wrap it up
real quick Etsy bonta's everywhere
you guys are great so thank you guys
very much
Evon setts ever a twitch Twitter YouTube
ghost ahead of Red Queen we're gonna
raid her over there so you guys are
great and for everybody else go donate
help the kids all that stuff is
definitely really important to do and
other than that you guys have been
absolutely awesome today so seriously
thank you guys very much and for episode
79 79 it has been the last word